et on le disait couture bonsoir je le
disais en introduction beaucoup de
canadiens qui ont décidé d'aller voter
durant cette longue fin de semaine tout
à fait on a des chiffres tout frais vous
en avez parler d'entrée de jeu lors de
vos marchés de patrice donc 2,4 millions
d'électeurs pour les trois jours donc
vendredi samedi et dimanche c'est 16 %
de plus qu'en 2011 ce sont des chiffres
qui sont sortis par élections canada il
ya quelques minutes à peine
effectivement un engouement qui est
quand même en fait sans équivoque qui
est beaucoup plus grand que les
dernières années est ce que les gens
profité du long week-end pour se
déplacer peut-être que leur idée était
faite du moins il ya eu le problème
quelques ratés une heure deux heures
jusqu'à 3 heures d'attentes nous at on
rapporté au manitoba également à halifax
donc il fallait s'armer de patience on a
rencontré quelques électeurs justement
qui étaient venus exercer leur droit de
vote par anticipation
ça fait assez longtemps que ça dure que
l'on où c'est pourquoi pour qui pour
quoi vous avez pas besoin d'une semaine
de plus pour faire votre réflexion
j'avais même pas besoin de réflexion
place et ils vont revenir lundi
c'est l'enfer donc on le voit élections
canada certains endroits qui a été
dépassé là un peu dépassée c'est sûr
qu'on offre moins d'endroits pour voter
que lors de la journée du scrutin
général donc lundi prochain il ya 3500
bureaux de vote qui était ouvert donc ce
week-end contre 19000 patrice qui seront
tout va lundi prochain il ya ça il ya un
peu moins d'effectifs
le processus d'identification est
beaucoup plus long et il ya cet
engouement lathion pantone un
superviseur de la circonscription de
papineau
on travaille fort depuis trois jours
maintenant
voyez-vous ici on est au chalet au guide
vie dans le comté de papineau
puis on a vraiment
une affluence record on a vraiment voter
au dessus de 200 personnes à chaque jour
pour une table de vote
les gens sont patients les gens sont
résilients les électeurs veulent voter
on est très très très content de voir
que les gens collaborent comprennent
quand on leur explique
puis pour l'instant ça va très bien donc
il ya des gens qui ont compris dont ils
ont trouvé ça un peu plus long pas très
sain d'un voté par anticipation
cela dit il reste encore les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas sortis
mais on espère bien sûr celle élections
canada que cet engouement cet
enthousiasme des électeurs va se
reproduire
lundi le 19 octobre prochain pour le
scrutin général et que le taux de
participation dépassera celui de 2011
qui était de 61 pour ça oui c'est un pas
très élevé à 61 merci je vous en prie au
revoir